warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised you know most people spend
between that play video games spend
between 40 and 60 hours per month do you
know how long it takes to listen to the
Bible is about that much this is
wild 80 hours isn't that amazing so you
can finish read the read listening to
the whole Bible in a little over a month
a little over one month of the average
people play video games wow one month
you could listen to the Bible wow now
that that suggests a significant amount
of time but at the same time people that
are playing 40 to 60 hours of video
games a month that's a significant
amount of
time all right welcome everyone to
another episode of LED live we are here
today and my co-workers are going to
play a game woohoo I didn't tell him
what the game was about so this should
be fun let's see who's playing we have
Scotty we have denique what's up and we
have Felipe hello hello both these guys
are representing with lightwear shirts
so you want to check that out lightwear
Dosh go get one we're playing guest the
Bible verse so here's how this is going
to go we are going to see what is the
movie I'm going to show you a screenshot
from a film I'm going to ask you
hopefully I'll remember to ask if you've
seen it yes or no and then you're going
to guess the Bible verse so all these
films films have Bible verses
interesting okay you ever seen a film
with a Bible verse in it I do I see
besides a religious film yes cuz these
are all sometimes in bad films
non-religious films okay you guys ready
yep okay here we go which scene is this
pul fiction pul fiction you got it right
away it's kind of very iconic look for
that film you don't see samel Jackson
with hair many movies going to give you
a multiple choice but apparently you
didn't need it these are all Samuel
Jackson films so okay you got it right
it was Pulp Fiction so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to play the clip
for you and I want you to listen closely
to his
dialogue okay and then we're going to uh
we're going to break that down okay all
right here we go all right you guys have
all seen this
fortunately yes you have I have not but
I have seen this clip you seen this clip
yes so I already know which vers already
know what what we're what we're going
after never seen so maybe he should have
the first guess here we go you read the
Bible yes well there's this passage I
got memorized sort of fits this occasion
Ezekiel 25
17 the path of the righteous man is
beset on all all sides by the inequities
of the selfish and the tyranny of evil
men blessed is he who in the name of
Charity and Good Will Shepherds the weak
through the valley of darkness for he is
truly his brother's keeper and the
finder of lost children and I will
strike down upon thee with great
Vengeance and Furious anger those who
attempt to poison and destroy my
brothers and you will know my name is
the Lord when I lay my vengeance upon
thee I'm going to spare you the yes than
you I was ready to go rest of that yeah
no I cut it off okay so here is the
dialogue this is what he said in that
section I think he's blending things
together yeah why do you think that I I
I when I so I did a show on uh showing
you what music teenagers tend to listen
to and the reason why I stumbled upon
this this is nothing to do with music
obviously is because Ariana Grande in
her music video um God is a woman
there's a section in there where she
throws this um what do you call it the
Jud judgment the judgement Hammer
through the the sky like the gavel gav
she through the javel through the sky
and she basically quoted this from Pulp
Fiction but then when I looked into it
this is a uh emerging of scripture it's
not really scripture and he kind of put
his own words to it here's the thing
though if you didn't know it sounds old
testony like the old yeah it sounds like
it comes from the Bible right yeah
especially something like you know
Ezekiel or something obscure you're like
not really something so I want to show
you this is Ezekiel
25:17
myute upon them with f anger fous
rebukes and they shall know that I am
the Lord when I shall lay my vengeance
upon them okay so now here what we're
going to do we're going to do a
comparison right here
is the portion that he quoted but with
the verse or as much of the verse as I
could highlight in there only in the end
only in the end that whole first section
does not exist in the verse it's not
there at all so pretty much only the
part where he points the gun at the guy
is when he's actually quoting the verse
yeah but he says he's quoting you know
and then he starts on his little tiate
so what do you notice here between the
verse that we read and what he has is
there any difference do you see any
difference I mean he's certainly picking
the the the violent asps of the verse he
is here's here's here's the highlighted
difference right there did you see it
Furious anger Furious anger
right why is that important because this
because the verse actually says Furious
rebukes right what is a rebuke like
you're doing something wrong yeah yeah
it's a correction right so dictionary
says it's sharp disapproval or criticism
because of behavior or actions right
what's
anger anger it doesn't always have to be
because of Correction it doesn't right
yeah so again it's like a strong feeling
of annoyance displeasure or hostility it
doesn't necessarily matter what it is
you can just be
angry so with anger the reason can be
very very subjective right it's based on
you know the human passion whatever
you're thinking but God's not like that
and here he's kind of almost putting
himself in like in that Godlike figure
cuz about to be the one to execute
judgment right with the gun but God has
reasons and so if he's rebuking his
children it's because of behavior or
actions not just because right God has a
reason for doing what he does but this
would give you a false idea it just
changed it just a little bit right just
a little bit but it's enough that it
gives you the wrong idea and I think in
this movie in the end they're discussing
this passage actually okay and um he
says I don't even know what it means it
just sounded cool you know and so even
he is admitting that he's just taking
the parts that oh yeah that sounds cool
and saying that and then adapting it to
his yeah yeah his purpose yeah sounds
like scripture if you didn't know any
better you'd be like oh that's that's
what the Bible says I really wonder how
many people looked up the verse and
actually like you know maybe read the
context of it you know yeah it speaks to
you need to know the context of
something well it does that's a good
question because um if you think about
it what happens in your brain when you
are watching a movie are you in the
active beta brain waves and actively
processing what it's saying or are you
in the alpha waves where you're being
lulled almost in a transl state and
everything goes right in but it
surpasses your frontal L with which you
actually can reason and think and make
decisions so it surpasses the rer L I
don't think that they're going to see
this and think about it I think it's
really dangerous too to skip around in
the Bible and make it you can make it
say whatever you want to and there's
plenty of sociopaths in our world that
have actually you know Blended spiritual
Concepts together if you read morals and
Dogma that book is completely blending
Freemason book yeah it's blending of
like um the Bible and then just weird
things doesn't make makes sense so so
it's more disturbing if your brain is
registering all these things out of
context
Anda you had an experience like that at
the at a Christian college right with
Fight Club yeah that scene our fathers
were our models for God if our fathers
bailed what does that tell you about
God listen to me I have to consider the
possibility that God does not like you
never wanted you in all probability he
hates you this is not the worst thing
that can happen isn't we don't need him
we don't like we I damn Nation man
Redemption we are God's unwanted
children so be
it listen you can run water over your
hand to make it worse or look at me or
you can use vinegar to neutralize the
burn please let me have first you have
to give up first you have to know not
fear know that someday you're going to
die you don't know how this feels
[Music]
it's only after we've lost everything
that we're free to do
[Music]
anything
okay mhm MH yeah just just the question
of of you know how many people have seen
this uh there was a room full of about
four or 500 people and um you can see
most of their hands we were actually
videoing it almost all the hands went up
and and no one could remember in that
movie Fight Club where they talk about
God and one person actually in the back
he raised his hand but they but they
totally just like tore God to pieces and
these were Christians said the the words
were God does not like you in fact God
hates you we don't need God we don't
forget Redemption forget salvation all
that kind of stuff and he says this huge
like long monologue basically how much
God hates you so that was surprising to
me that people in the room couldn't
remember that and that that speaks to
the point of like these words are going
in your brain mhm and there's there
there's also this danger of when we
watch a movie we end up memorizing yeah
this the script yeah right I remember
growing up uh me and my my brother would
always be saying stuff and my dad was
like where's that from oh it's from such
cartoon such movie and he's like okay
tell me a Bible verse yeah from memory
right you know job so when people watch
movies like Pulp Fiction and they have
disc script memorized some people might
think okay I memorized a Bible verse
right and a Samuel Jackson verse but
it's not actually a Bible verse yeah
right we can see where where where uh
Satan in Matthew 4 also took
scripture context and actually that's a
really interesting point that you just
said there because Satan he did not use
the whole verse exactly just like here
he was actually only quoting part of it
and yeah interesting and it was only
because Jesus knew and memorized the
words that he could counter Satan and
overcome knew yeah he knew it exactly
excellent points okay okay next one
which movie is this scen from and before
you answer I do have a multiple choice
so if you think you know it keep it in
your head and then I was going to say it
is it one of these yes no idea I will I
will guess an answer let the millenni do
you think it is
uh Foot Loose looks like a good one I'm
guessing A Few Good Men okay you're
wrong yeah she's right random random
piic this is an older Kevin Bacon movie
y I was in first grade when this movie
came out okay oh W very specific 19 I
was Bor how old were you in first grade
probably five turning six oh yeah I was
not even on this planet no nope so
you're right it is from the movie Foot
Loose okay so I want to show you this
one's probably going to be the longest
clip that I'm going to show you from the
different films but this one's necessary
to kind of really set the stage in the
context of what's going on on okay and
actually I'm only breaking down one
verse but he actually doesn't quote
scripture once he actually quotes it
twice so here we go show you the
clip well I just I just wanted to say a
few words about this motion so that uh
you would you wouldn't think that we
were encouraging
destruction with this
idea from the oldest of times people
danced for a number of
reasons they danced in prayer or so that
their crops would be plentiful or so
their hunt would be
good and they dance to stay physically
fit and show their Community
spirit and they danced to
celebrate and that that is the dancing
that we're talking about yeah AR
told in in Psalm
149 praise ye the
Lord sing unto the Lord a new
song Let Them praise His name in the
dance amen
amen and it was King
David King David who who we read about
in in
Samuel and and and what did David do
what did David do what did David do
David
danced before the Lord with all his
might
leaping leaping and dancing before the
Lord leaping and
dancing in
Ecclesiastes assures
us that there is there is a time to
every purpose under
[Music]
Heaven a time to
laugh and a time to
weep a time to
mourn and there is a time to
[Music]
dance and there was a time for the this
law not
anymore see this is our time to dance it
is our way of of celebrating
life that's the way it was in the
beginning it's the way it's always
been that's the way it should be
now so I'm I'm guessing the context is
is this like a courtroom or something
yeah what's this movie about yeah it's
not not quite like a courtroom it's more
like a like a town hall yeah City Hall
type setting and they're not allowed to
dance yeah so there's this rule against
dancing in their their community and
there's this group of people that that
enjoy dancing and want want to dance so
he straight had the Bible out and read
from it right I don't think Ecclesiastes
uses the word dance does it a time for
mourning and a time for Joy look it up
yeah I don't I don't I don't know if it
actually uses the word dance does it
look it up I don't remember what he said
what what the verse was in Ecclesiastes
but the part I wanted to focus on though
um for this is he said Psalm 149 praise
ye the Lord sing unto the Lord a new
song Let Them praise His name in the
dance right okay this is the part he
quoted from the film
this is Psalm 149 the first three verses
okay you want to read this for us yeah
sure praise ye the Lord sing unto the
Lord a new song and his praise in the
congregation of saints let Israel
rejoice in him that made him let the
children of Zion be joyful in their King
let them praise His name in The Dance
Let Them sing praises unto him with the
timberl and harp and harp
it's like a tamarine so Ecclesiastes it
does use the word dance yeah it does use
the word dance so this is what the verse
actually says this is from Psalm 149
veres 1 through3 now the reason I chose
all three verses is because if you look
and compare what he
said this is his quote highlighted in
yellow what did he leave
out oh where where where should we
praise the Lord he left out vers vers
two entirely right so if we go and show
verse two highlighted in blue let Israel
rejoice in him that made him let the
children of Zion be joyful and their
King why is this important I think it
sets the stage of of an act of worship
in the act of dance so who is your who
do you serve it is the god right it is
the King Kings it's it's the Lord and so
if you know that what is your dance
going to be like because there's a
variety of dancing um I don't think that
when David danced before the Lord that
he was going to you know shake all of
his body parts and
um dance erotically like you do in the
clubs yeah I think what he did was he
was kind of like yeah I'm so glad God
thank you and just kind of skipped and
hobbled and
just was having his his physical
reaction out of excitement for what God
had done not like let me show everybody
my physique and show off
sensually yeah exactly it's not like art
rated like what we do today in in this
film I highly doubt that there was any
religious thoughts that these kids were
doing while they were doing those dances
you can tell by the way that they ended
the dialogue he's like this is a way to
celebrate life right right yeah well
that has nothing to do with the verse
the verse especially focusing on verse
two in the context of the film they're
just going to do um they're going to the
Bible as a way to justify their dancing
right but as if that's some kind of
god-given right like you have a
god-given right to dance just just
because just because the Bible says so
but the Bible reason for giving the
singing and the dancing is in the second
verse it's to rejoice in God
that makes you joyful and because he is
your king not because you're just
celebrating life and because you just
want to dance right right and I
guarantee you those parents or the city
council that was having that meeting
they they they were bringing religion
into it probably saying like we should
not be acting like this lewdly and you
know they were probably even you I don't
know it's been I think I've seen this
parts and bits when I was a kid but um
um you know I'm sure they were using the
Bible to justify why they should not be
dancing like that which is almost in a
weird way exactly what Satan did with
Jesus right and then all of a sudden
flipping the oh really the Bible says it
like this now but not using it in that
context right and that's why he's
throwing it back in their face and
bringing them the Bible and pointing to
them and like see there it says you can
dance yeah see I can play your game
Satan says that to Jesus but they're
both taking it out of context right and
so it gives a false impression suggest
what they're doing is biblical when
they're reasoning is
not so you got to be careful right and
and here they're not just quoting the
whole verse he's they're quoting the
parts that are convenient to make their
point and that's what he was doing with
the city council he wasn't um quoting
the entire thing just kind of skipping
around all right here's the next one
before you guess before you guess I got
a multiple choice okay so which scene or
which movie is this scene from is it a A
B C or D ding ding ding ding I think a I
think it's a I think it's Ghostbusters
okay Ghostbusters you're right it is
Ghostbusters very iconic look for a film
okay do you know they quote scripture in
Ghostbusters good never seen it either
yeah this one's a little different okay
but I'm going to show you the the
portion now Dan akroy was a co-writer on
Ghostbusters at least the first one
which is is from so now Dan Arro is not
a believer in God he's a self-proclaimed
spiritualist but not a believer in God
yeah or he believes there's a spirit
world so there could be a Hees there a
spirit world but I don't I don't know
specifically where he stands J Christian
idea think so I don't think so okay here
we
go he Ray do you believe in God never
met him yeah well I do and I love
Jesus's style you know this roof C is
made of a magnesium tungsten
alloy what are you so involved with here
these are the blueprints for the
structural iron work in Dana Barrett's
apartment building and they're very very
strange hey Ray do you remember
something in the Bible about the last
days when the dead would rise from the
grave I remember Revelations
7:12 and I looked as he opened the Sixth
Seal and behold there was a great
earthquake and the sun became as black
as sackcloth and the moon became as
blood and the Seas boiled and the skies
fell Judgment Day Judgment
Day every ancient religion has its own
myth about the end of the world
myth Ray has it ever occurred to you and
maybe the reason we've been so busy
lately is because the dead have been
rising from the
[Music]
grave you're laughing over here like
almost hysterically wow this this so out
of context right now wow okay so I'm
going to show you what he said this is
what he said okay this is the this is
the quote from the film between the
between the two guys okay so do you
know this verse how how close does this
seem to you not off the top of my head I
don't this is this is not it this is
this is definitely not referring to
Judgment Day either yes so I'm going to
show you the I'm going to show you the
verse okay and then tell me if you see
anything different yeah I I I I thought
about that how in the end I was like it
doesn't say anything about the SE
boiling and oh good catch good catch
good catch yeah so also look at the
reference 6 verse 12 that's 6 vers not
72 oh interesting I quoted it wrong
which is easy to do I mean I'll give him
a little bit
of but he wrote it script I mean you
don't have any fact check that I mean I
don't think they care it does seem like
you would fact check that maybe he
didn't want people looking it up so it
was mostly quoted correctly but the
reference was in incorrect right and
that could that could be an honest
mistake we'll give him that um easy to
do I'm sure we probably do that from
time to time but I'm going to highlight
the portion that is actually from
scripture there it
is so the part that Dan
akroy said was actually the part that's
in the Bible mhm okay but the Seas
boiling that's not actually in the verse
yep that part's not in scripture um now
the skies falling are actually mentioned
in uh Revelation 613 in the next verse
it starts to mention that and of course
um they're using this to talk about
apocalyptic events you know they're
looking at like this is the end of the
world right and the Dead Rising that's
the part I was I was laughing about Dead
Rising cuz of the ghosts all coming out
of and There and Everywhere yes but but
if you really think about the timing of
all that right when do the dead
rise it's well for one those who
crucified Jesus will see him come again
so that's those people will rise that's
on the great day of the Lord exactly but
it's a smaller few people that are like
coming up in this ghoulish State yes the
first people that resurrect are those
that died in Christ and they are
resurrected to meet him in the clouds
exactly Thessalonian says that yeah the
dead dead are not raised at that point
with a new body not as Spirit glorified
state they're not ghoulish blood the
righteous that are raised yeah right
then those people who you know crucified
Jesus it talks to there will be a
millennium and there's nothing on the
Earth but Satan and his angels for a
thousand years so those who crucified
Jesus will go dead again and then there
will be the official Resurrection where
he tells people go and attack the New
Jerusalem and then God says enough
destroyed after a thousand years right
so so these are actually all signs that
point toward Christ's second coming when
you look at this here there's there's a
few things there's the earthquake that's
mentioned right speaking of the great
lisban earthquake that happened in
1755 there's also the dark day it says
the sun became black as sackcloth right
this is also a sign it would happened in
1780 the dark day you can look these
things up in history they all happened
um before or some before and one of them
during America's second grade awakening
and the last one talks about the the
skies falling which is actually in verse
uh 13 but that's referring to the
1833 uh Leonid meteor storm where it
looked like this the stars were falling
and and some people said there was many
as um what was it
40 was it 40 a minute 40 meteors a
minute or 40 I don't know 40 a minute or
40 a second I mean whatever it was it
was like a lot and it was just looked
like it was bright as day outside bright
as day outside that's so cool so that's
what this is referring to and these are
all signs that point to the fact that
Jesus was coming soon so not not you
know ghosts sir coming out from here and
there and everywhere but there's also
another verse I wanted to reference
Revelation 22:19 Scotty would you read
that and if any man shall take away from
the words of the book of this prophecy
God shall take away his part out of the
book of life and out of the out of the
holy city and from the things which are
written in this book got to be careful
right with the Book of Revelation that
we're not adding to taking away
removing and that's that's exactly what
we saw a little bit you know he they had
added a little bit about the Seas
boiling right it's not there are are
they is this verse specifically speaking
speaking about just Revelation or is it
speaking about the book of the Bible the
whole it is speaking about the Book of
Revelation yeah and so you got to be
careful right God asks us not to not to
do that we shouldn't do that leave it as
it is it's written the way God wants it
to be written yeah because if you were
to Tinker it it would alter what happens
and and honestly God's already told us
what's happened thousands of years prior
because that's proving that God is real
so the devil would love to change these
words sure sure would yeah so anyway
that's just a warning that's contained
in the book leave it alone don't alter
it okay next one we're probably yeah
we're on number four so two more left so
you may recognize where this is from and
I going give you some multiple choice
options okay think I might know you
think you know is it AB B C or D D D I'm
saying D just because it's the only
title I recognize yeah it is I watched
this I can't even tell you how many
times I've watched the sh Wait before
you start did you pick up on the Bible
verses when you were watching it no and
this one is a lot more obscure well
that's interesting though this is a lot
more obscure this one you would not just
necessarily pick up on and I'll explain
why okay
okay um yeah so this is from the
Shashank Redemption play the clip and
then we'll get into the explanation of
why this is more unusual okay it's only
about 30 seconds long toss and Sals was
just an
excuse truth is nordon wanted to size
Andy
[Music]
up my wife made that in church
group very nice sir all right that's all
I'm giving you that's it that's there
was nothing that
was the Bible verse I was trying to
catch the one that was on the wall so
this is what he said my wife made that
in church that was a quote and this is
what he was referring to okay you saw
this there it pulled rack Focus to focus
specifically on this plaque now where is
this in the Bible his judgment cometh
and that right soon that doesn't even
really make sense
well we know we know where was it like
Revelation 14 it says you know the hour
of his judgment has come is true the
first Angel's message we we we do know
that that quote specific I can't I don't
think this is a specific quote from the
Bible I think it's no I think it's an
amalgamation of things or it's the
concept of judgment in Christ's second
coming but he because he says his his
wife made this in in church group right
so you're given the idea the seeds being
planted in your head this came from
church came from the Bible from a you're
thinking it came from about Jesus in the
right right hand is it okay so here's
where it came
from Nique will you read this a prayer
out of a poor man's mouth reacheth to
the ears of God and his judgment cometh
speedily and the reference Ecclesiastes
215 no it's not actually Ecclesiastes
it's
ecclesiasticus what 215 is where is that
is this of the Apocrypha it is from the
Apocrypha
that's why I didn't recognize
it like man I need to read my Bible more
I was like I don't think that sounds
like from the Bible but all right yeah
you guys did pretty good yeah but if you
didn't know any better in the context of
the clip and the film is planting the
idea you're thinking this is from
scripture but it's not right it's from
the Apocrypha yeah and the Apocrypha is
very much
questionable people have mixed feelings
about that some things in there seem
like they very well could be in the
Bible and other things are like that
does not agree with the rest of
scripture so yeah it's it's kind of a
touchy subject for
people all right here we go next one so
he's constantly quoting the Bible what
do you think that movie I haven't seen
it so I'm going to go with the Book of
Eli cuz I haven't seen ien seen the Book
of Eli I mean the Fallen sounds kind of
biblical so I'll go with that one okay
you two are right it is the Book of Eli
I'm going to read you the synopsis okay
okay 30 years after the war turned the
world into a wasteland a lone Warrior
named Eli marches across the ruined
landscape carrying Hope For Humanity's
Redemption only one other man
understands the power of what Eli
carries and he is determined to take it
for himself though Eli prefers peace he
will risk death to protect his precious
gargo for he must fulfill his Destiny to
help restore
mankind okay so now we're going to go to
you were right it was the book of Eli
I'm going to play that clip
okay cursed be the
ground for our
sake both thorns and thistles it shall
bring
forth for
us for out of the ground we were taken
for the Dust We Are
and to the dust we shall
return God said those words back in Cain
and Abel's day pretty sure that was uh
for for Adam curs beat the ground for
thy sake and and that's true yes yeah
yeah I thought he was saying it to Cain
after he murdered that's what I thought
initially
is okay Prett good this is what he said
MH okay this is the quote from the film
and here is the here is the closest
section of scripture it's Genesis 3:17
to9 exactly what you guys were referring
to I'm going to show
you the parts that he quoted so Snippets
from um verse 17 verse 18 and verse 19
it's kind of picked a little bit um and
here's what's not mentioned and the
reason is important here's what's not
mentioned okay thou Hast eaten of the
tree of which I commanded thee saying
Thou shalt not eat of
it why is that
important it's not just something that
God did to make Humanity miserable right
the curse doesn't exist just because God
is like
well got to do something to make these
guys you know miserable punish them it's
a consequence for actions that are taken
on our behalf right and that's important
in Deuteronomy
28-30 God lays out the path of obedience
for the children of Israel right and
Disobedience he says if you obey this
will happen you'll you'll have blessings
if you disobey this will happen there'll
be cursings right but it's a conditional
cause and effect situation it's not just
God hurling down lightning bolts to you
know at Humanity so if you follow God
there will be blessings and if you
choose not to follow God there'll be
curses so again it context becomes very
important right it's not just the ground
is cursed just just because the ground
is cursed
God has a reason for the things that he
does there's a whole lot of stuff here
that's missing yeah I was going to say
um the things that are missing about
like there will be thorns and thistles
and you you shall eat the herb of the
field and the sweater of thy face shalt
thou eat bread all of these things are
God's ways to redeem us it's his way to
save us because he's saying you're
living in sin you're going to have a a
lot of struggles to stay close to me but
the aspect of work and having to put in
the effort will grow your character to
the point where you become reflective of
me again that's what this is for he
wasn't doing it like well I'm just going
to make you work harder he's like this
is going to be a blessing to you
yeah so why do we look at all these
things it's easy to miss them right just
like you said earlier when you're
watching these things the way your brain
operates the way it responds to
television media entertainment stuff on
the internet video games all of that it
becomes easy to miss because your brain
isn't processing things the normal way
so you can be taking in a whole bunch of
things that seem like scripture but
you're not critically analyzing them
you're not sitting there going oh that's
not
scripture and and I say that for most
people sure there's the there's the
person here and there that that does
that because they their brain hasn't
switched forever reason in that moment
right but by and large this is how we
behave as human beings and so you miss
them and if you're not familiar with the
with your Bible what does that mean
you're going to be susceptible to these
things that plant seeds that are not
true false ideas right and you're coming
to a time in history where knowing the
Bible is very important knowing the
difference between truth and error is
very important Jesus said multiple times
in m Matthew 24 do not be deceived right
because we're coming to a time of great
deception and the verse I want to land
land on for the end here is the one from
2 Timothy 2:15 it says study to show
thyself approved unto God a Workman that
needeth not be ashamed rightly dividing
the word of Truth this is what God has
called us to ask to do right to study to
know our Bibles so that when those
important times come we are not going to
be deceived and we're not going to get
scripture properly from this Source
right from Hollywood you guys have any
last comments you want to throw out here
or maybe a film you remember that did
have something like that that you uh
that we didn't discuss there's others I
didn't I didn't there was another one I
thought about putting in but I didn't
put it in I just wanted to bring up that
we have a documentary called pseudology
this is true where people can uh watch
for an hour long about how uh the brain
is influenced by your movies and
Hollywood and all these things we just
talked about about beta brain wavs and
Alpha brain waves and how it supresses
to falope all of that there's actually a
lot of video games that work in biblical
Concepts maybe maybe not Bible verses
but biblical Concepts Assassin's Creed
like Call of Duty start talk about the
mark of the beast and Assassin's Creed
as he you know things about the papacy
and the crucifixion the crci grand auto
man he was playing he had a Judas
character yeah yeah yeah true was
Michael the saint yeah yeah that's
interesting it can shape your ideas you
know most people spend between that play
video games spend between 40 and 60
hours per month do you know how long it
takes to listen to the Bible is about
that much this is
wild 80 hours isn't that amazing so you
can finish re the read listening to the
whole Bible a little over a month a
little over one month of the average
people play video games wow one month
you could listen to the Bible wow now
that that suggests a significant amount
of time but at the same time people that
are playing 40 to 60 hours of video
games a month that's a significant
amount of time some kids will play eight
hours in a day I mean some some will
depending on the day only 10 days so
yeah and I I I remember having a a drive
to work I used to spend half an hour
going a half an hour coming back and I
would listen to The Bible and I remember
I made it through the whole Bible mult
multiple times doing that on that drive
over a period of I don't know how long
it was couple couple years yeah so I
know it can be done they're they're on
YouTube yeah I mean seriously you can
type in Bible there's somebody reading
the Bible right there so Spotify Spotify
any of these things I think I think you
know God has made it accessible to
everyone everywhere however you want to
digest it the funny thing is is
everybody has a Bible in their home but
most people don't read it oh and more
everybody's got a Bible in their pocket
you got a Bible in your pocket you got a
Bible everywhere yeah we have to
remember that you know the Bible is used
for preaching the Bible is used for
teaching but movies are also used for
preaching and teaching that's true and
when they use the Bible in movies then
it gets even more interesting because
then what are you
preaching because then people will start
connecting oh if the Bible teaches me
the way of living and they're using the
Bible in movies if validates whatever
it's being said in the movie or the
action or whatever which makes it even
more we should be cautious when watching
right or or or enjoying entertainment
for that matter what was that director
called again that said um basically this
is what we directors do in Hollywood
flip a little more at
themi yeah flip a little what my view of
the world is at them cuz that's what all
good filmmakers do he literally says it
I mean yeah um so I I always like to
think of it as like I've got him sitting
there whip a little message at him whip
a little moral at him whip a little of
what my view of the world is cuz that's
what every good filmmaker does that's
what they do here but it's usually done
in this cogni cognitive dissidence way
like where it doesn't the what's being
read doesn't match what's being done
like Kevin Kevin Bacon's um Foot Loose
right there like he's using the Bible to
justify dancing for for praising God and
that's the references that he was using
yet they're dancing in a debaucherous
way um just watching the trailer to that
wild robot it's like the song in the
background is what a beautiful world and
you're seeing this you're seeing the
storm and everything wreck and so it's
like you're hearing beautiful world but
you're seeing this and that's often what
they do in these these when they use
these quotes yeah it's like they're
they're quoting something that otherwise
would be this thing that would teach you
or be this beautiful thing but then
they're showing you a guy with a gun
that's just wanting to blow this guy's
head off and cause him judgment mov does
that beginning of the film they use the
song Everything Is Awesome at to the end
of the film when the book of
instructions has been disregarded
they're you know taking down lord
business they play the song again
everything is awesome when creativity
Reigns nobody has to obey the rules and
all that so it's a reassociation in your
mind like a rebranding of what awesome
looks like y wow so it's a good point
that you made you go and you go and and
um just about every film is a sermon
right got that from this guy and you
think about that it's not you can take
that a step further and it's like yeah
so you go and go to the theater it's
like giving an offering right I mean
it's pretty crazy you're going to pay to
hear a message challenge to our audience
your your where you spend your money as
a form of worship as well what is worthy
of your giving to that right so I I I
love the challenge of going look if you
go to movies all the time and you have
an easy time putting 20 bucks in that
little movie ticket box try putting 20
bucks in the offering plate next time
you go to
church well thank you for your insights
in your discussion guys it was fun a
little different and uh I hope it was
insightful to you the viewer uh it's why
we do this we do this because we're
we're sharing our thoughts and what's on
our mind and the things that we see and
I hope that's something that you've
never seen before or never thought about
before and it gives you cost to pause
and reflect and say yeah how am I
spending my time and am I taking in
things that aren't helping me in my walk
with God so with that we're going to
sign off and um remember you can support
this ministry by going to
ls. we just updated our donation
workflow so it's even easier uh we have
actually a donor match going on right
now so if you see this video years later
hopefully that's already fulfilled but
uh for our building fund our studio um
so you want to support that you can go
to our website and find that um we
already mentioned the shirts
make sure you like comment subscribe we
want to hear what you think about this
um you think you totally agree with us
you think it's a stretch we want to hear
from you want to make sure that we're
crafting our information in a way that's
helpful and attractive to other people
so we will see you next time thank you
for joining us on LED live take care
[Music]
[Applause]
Jacob and he for you
Israel make the pillar in the temple of
my God and he shall go out no more I
will ride on him the name of my
God strong in the Lord and in the power
Lord shall your strength shall
M shall
R I pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
[Music]